as atrocities in ukraine mount the
country's ambassador appealed to the
general assembly to hold russia
accountable and suspend them from the
geneva-based human rights council all
you need to do
is to press the yes button
and to save the human rights council
and many lives around the world
and in ukraine
on the other hand
pressing no
means pulling a trigger
russia denying all wrongdoing accused
the west of double standards
what we're seeing today is an attempt by
the united states to maintain its
dominant position and total control to
continue its attempt at human rights
colonialism in international relations
russia lobbied hard convincing china to
vote against suspension
such a hasty move at the general
assembly which forces countries to
choose sides will aggravate the division
among member states intensify the
confrontation between the parties
concerned it is like adding fuel to the
fire
in the end 23 countries sided with
russia 93 voted in favor of suspension
but india brazil and south africa were
among 58 countries that abstained saying
an investigation should be concluded
first mexico also abstained i think it
creates more polarization a country that
supported previous resolutions deploring
russia's aggression
mexico is in favor of everything that
will keep inclusion and dialogue on the
table
still the u.s ambassador who initiated
the vote hailed the decision as a
victory
today the international community took
one collective step in the right
direction
we ensured a persistent and egregious
human rights violator will not be
allowed to occupy a position of
leadership on the human on human rights
at the u.n
the 47-member human rights council
launched an investigation into possible
war crimes in ukraine while russia was
still a member over russia's objections
now it will release its findings without
russia who after becoming only the
second country to be suspended from the
council announced it was quitting
kristin salumi al jazeera the united
nations